right so we looked at multiplication and
division is a natural next place to go
because multiplication and division are
kind of two sides of the same coin
one does and the other one undoes so
when we think about division a lot of
what we thought about for multiplication
will help okay
so just remember how we summarized
before when you're multiplying so long
as the bases are the same and a you add
the powers right so you should keep on
the back of your mind let's think about
what this means now just like before
rather than go straight to the answer I
want to try and expand this first so I
can see why the answer is what it is so
7 to the power of 5 how we expand this
this is yes here do not yeah we will all
get to the answer but before we get
there do not expand it for me nailed it
okay there's our 7 to the power of 5 now
I could put brackets around it and then
write a division sign but I said think
that something might help you visually
it helps me is if we actually write this
division now as a big old fraction okay
you might like to use your ruler if you
find it hard to make straight fraction
lines like I do sometimes that's on the
top 7 to the power of 5 and now I'm
dividing by 7 squared there's 7 times 7
okay now by this time we've been dealing
with fractions for quite some time one
of things were really good at is
simplify fractions writing ones that are
equivalent by looking for things on the
top of the bottom that we can cancel out
that match on the top of the bottom okay
so what do you see marry excellent yeah
I can totally see this 217 that matched
with these two 7s here so these guys can
cancel with these ones so what I'll be
left with after I get rid of all of
those extra sevenths
yeah it's 1 2 3 so it's 7 how do we say
it cubes very good now just like before
did you notice if we have a look at the
powers there's another relationship from
these powers on the left right to get to
this over on the right what do you see
yeah Haley go ahead
fantastic if we - the palace 5-2 when we
get three right and which you should
have sort of expected because you're
like oh we're doing the opposite of
multiplying we're doing division so
therefore instead of adding the powers
you should do the opposite of adding you
should do subtraction now in that case I
wonder if you can help me go straight to
the answer we don't even need to write
the big old fraction for this how're we
going to write if we think about
subtracting the powers what are we gonna
get yeah go ahead
ah very good so there's the first little
sneaky thing there's a one that's hiding
it and then what four minus one which
you can all tell me is all right two
cubed so you do have to watch out for
those sneaky little ones that are just
kind of hanging out there invisibly for
take away ones sure enough gives you
three so now we can summarize it it's
going to look very similar to this one
that we wrote up here right if you've
got two numbers and they have the same
base right so if you've got a to the
power of M and a to the power of n again
so same base different powers but if
instead you're dividing how would you
write this thing on the end is a to the
power of M minus n m takeaway him that's
it so you know how he said before when
multiplying you add the powers how would
you say it instead for this yeah go
ahead
yeah when dividing I'm gonna say
subtract the powers I said okay I'm
gonna even put it here label it like
that when dividing we are going to
subtract the powers
dance keys okay so it's kind of a bit
funny when you like oh is that all I
have to do all I have to do subtraction
but we've seen before a lot of math
sometimes is taking a hard really
weird-looking problem and converting it
into you are five take away two equals
three I could do that with my eyes
closed and hands are tied behind my back